lebanon is losing its battle with
coronavirus
and the winter season has yet to set in
doctors are treating patients in this
hospital's emergency wards in beirut
because beds are no longer available the
country's health sector
is overwhelmed we are seeing too many
patients
that are being going from hospital to
another for mainly two days three days
over over three four five days just
looking for a hospital to receive these
patients and these patients they are not
finding a place to be admitted and at
the end they are coming to the last
hospital
where they are admitted and they are not
doing good
more than half of the nearly 50 000
active cases in a nation of 6 million
people
have occurred in the past few weeks the
main
gate for the ar is completely closed
because we cannot anymore for today or
for at least
the coming hours to receive any new
patient
people are not abiding by the rule of
preventive measures
and there is no control from the
authorities there is no whatsoever
control
either in the major city but also in the
remote area
the authorities have responded to a call
by health workers to shut down the
country
the lockdown excludes the airport and
essential businesses
it will last two weeks before being
eased
the private sector is not happy already
businesses have been closing down
as an economic crisis impoverishes more
than half
of the population
there are days people can't afford to
eat it's a difficult time
a lockdown hurts many people instead
people should cooperate and wear masks
and the authorities should be strict in
enforcing rules
it will be the second nationwide closure
since march
at that time the cash-strapped
government couldn't help the poor
since then many more have become
vulnerable but authorities say they have
little option
to contain the outbreak
intensive care units have reached a
critical capacity
the positivity rate is high relative to
testing
which means the virus is spreading
quickly a few months ago there were
dozens of cases a day
now it reaches two thousand infection
among health workers is also rising
the lockdown may give hospitals time to
prepare for the difficult days
but without a long-term strategy it will
create new challenges for many lebanese
on the brink of bankruptcy senator
al-jazeera beirut